Franz Fanon trajectoire d'un révolté
documentaire réalisé par Audrey mourion
et Mathieu glissant le portrait vous
venez de le voir de celui qui demeure de
par ses écrits et son parcours comme
l'une des figures majeures de la lutte
contre le colonialisme l'occasion aussi
pour nous après ce film de nous
interroger sur le poids du racisme
post-colonial aujourd'hui dans notre
société c'est ce que nous allons faire
maintenant sur ce plateau de débat doc
en compagnie de nos invités Mathieu
glissant est avec nous bienvenue vous
êtes donc le corrélisateur avec Audrey
Morion de ce documentaire consacré à
Franz Fanon vous êtes auteur réalisateur
et vous êtes aussi le fils du poète et
philosophe Edward glissant disparu en
2011 qui s'était lié d'amitié d'ailleurs
avec Franz Fanon et à qui vous avez
consacré un autre documentaire intitulé
Edouard Glissant la créolisation du
monde et puis votre prochain film il
devrait être diffusé très bientôt chez
nos confrères de France 5 sera consacré
à Vichy dans les colonie Rachida Brahim
est avec nous également bienvenue vous
êtes psychanalyste sociologue votre
dernier livre s'intitule la race tue
deux fois édité aux éditions sileps vous
y analysez la dénonciation et le
traitement institutionnel des crimes
racistes en France de 1970 à 2000 sur
une base de données comportant
731 crimes racistes pour faire simple
vous vous êtes intéressé au crime
raciste et à l'heure impunité et puis
Dominique Sopo est également avec nous
bienvenue vous êtes le président de SOS
Racisme vous avez piloté l'association
de 2003 à 2012 puis de nouveau depuis
2014 SOS Racisme est né ras pour le en
1984 et plaid je cite pour la
construction d'une république métissée
qui tourne le dos à l'extrême droite et
à la conception communautariste de la
lutte antiraciste vous prenez toujours
le vivre ensemble dans notre pays et
dans notre société on va y venir bien
sûr au cours de cette émission je me
tourne tout de suite vers vous après
avoir vu ce ce documenter ce portrait de
Franz Fanon en quoi Franz Fanon
aujourd'hui en 2023 est-il encore
d'actualité
c'est une bonne question c'est vrai que
le film se termine sur cette ouverture
cet héritage de Fanon qu'on a en commun
aujourd'hui
je pense que bon le racisme existe
toujours les conséquences du
colonialisme les conséquences
disons psychiques
parfois même psychiatrique les
conséquences humaines dans différentes
dans différents domaines
existent encore
tout un tas de personnes les étudie et
fanons là dedans
pour moi en fait si vous voulez c'était
pas simplement de faire le portrait d'un
révolutionnaire
porte-parole d'une lutte armée pour la
libération nationale de l'Algérie par
exemple c'était aussi de faire le
portrait de quelqu'un qui
menait ce combat là tout en étant et en
portant en lui une forme d'identité
ouverte
ce qui est notable avec fannonce qui est
très impressionnant je trouve c'est que
au fil de sa vie son
identité sa pensée sa personne n'a cessé
d'être en mouvement n'a cessé d'évoluer
en fonction de ces expériences réelles
et il a adapté son œuvre au fil de ses
expériences
tout ça en s'ouvrant aux autres
et si vous voulez il y a quelque chose
qui m'a toujours qui m'a toujours marqué
c'est que c'est un homme qui est né en
Martinique qui est arrivé en France
Jeune jeune homme qui ensuite a été
affecté en Algérie et qui s'engage dans
les Forces de France de la France Libre
hein
qui pour libérer l'Europe et qui
successivement va
se dire martiniquais français algérien
et il va le faire sans jamais renier le
reste c'est à dire qu'il va être tout ça
à la fois
même si ça se bouscule en lui il y a
cette cette fluidité
identitaire qui n'est pas du tout un
frein à sa radicalité dans le combat
pour la liberté des peuples et ça c'est
quelque chose de très important c'est à
dire que pour moi Fanon c'est un
défenseur du devenir
c'est un défenseur de de la liberté mais
de la liberté qui porte sur l'avenir des
hommes plus qu'un défenseur de des
traditions par exemple ou de communautés
de communauté constituées en fonction du
passé
et donc et donc pour moi c'est une
figure qui peut qui peut voilà que tout
jeune se posant des questions sur le
racisme post-colonial le racisme de
maintenance c'est une figure qui peut
inspirer elle vous a inspiré cette
figure dans le cadre de vos travaux par
exemple et en quoi elle est pertinente
cette figure et en quoi ce parcours ses
écrits sont pertinents dans le sujet qui
nous préoccupe à la suite de ce film le
racisme post-colonial
oui enfin non est une grande figure de
la question du racisme la question
coloniale
c'est personnellement il m'a inspiré
dans le cadre de mes recherches donc ce
livre que vous avez cité est une étude
d'une thèse en doctorat de sociologie et
c'est un rapport ambivalent
parce que la question du racisme post
colonial donc post-coloniale entendu
comme chronologiquement après la
colonisation c'est un terme qui reste
entendable encore quand c'est posé en
ces termes-là quand on en vient à parler
d'études post-coloniale d'études des
coloniales de sulton study's de la
question raciale c'est encore des
concepts qui sont qui ont du mal à
émerger dans le contexte français et ma
thèse était très sur un sujet du coup
très là vous mettez le point sur un
point important ça a du mal à émerger
dans la société française ce thème du
racisme post colonial et c'est justement
pour ça qu'on a choisi d'en parler dans
cette émission pourquoi ça a du mal à
émerger
et bien précisément en raison de la
question coloniale qui
qui il y a tout un courant de pensée en
sociologie en sociologie critique qui
explique que le Colonial n'est pas fini
c'est ce qu'on appelle les études des
coloniales notamment qui sont beaucoup
décréés d'après certains théoriciens
donc c'est un mouvement qui n'est plutôt
dans le l'Amérique du Sud
on considère que la question connaît ne
s'est pas arrêtée au moment des
indépendances et que c'est un régime de
pouvoir en fait et au cœur de ce rythme
pouvoir il y a la question raciale qui
est sans cesse réactiver elle ne serait
pas arrêtée avec le nazisme ou avec les
indépendances des anciennes colonies
africaines elle aurait perdurer par de
là en fait on s'infiltrant dans les
politiques publiques à différents
endroits du monde social dans
différentes sphères et elle reste
extrêmement active et donc ça c'est un
c'est quelque chose qui qui a beaucoup
de mal à être entendu parce que c'est
extrêmement douloureux à différents
endroits de considérer que la race est
encore là et bien c'est comme si nos
idéaux s'effondraient en fait qu'il y
avait un é collective un endroit où on
parle d'humanité et de dignité et c'est
l'éternel contradiction on en parlera
avec
l'universalisme affichée par par la
République française évidemment c'est
vrai que on a souvent glorifié l'oeuvre
de la colonisation du côté des
responsables politiques et cependant
très longtemps c'est peut-être Emmanuel
Macron qui le premier à osé parler d'un
crime contre l'humanité il était pas
encore président
il n'a pas répété depuis qu'il est
président de de la République mais on a
souvent glorifié l'oeuvre de la
colonisation du côté des responsables
politiques et daigner ces crimes
assez de colonisation c'est votre
constat aussi et ça expliquerait pour
beaucoup peut-être le racisme colonial
dont souffre beaucoup de personnes
aujourd'hui alors le constat il est
évident puisque il suffit d'écouter les
discours des responsables politiques
pendant très longtemps sur le passé sur
le passé colonial ou pendant la période
coloniale ou en tout cas d'une grande
partie des responsables politiques avec
des euphémisations des volontés même en
reconnaissance la dimension violente
voire meurtrière de faire une forme de
balance jusqu'à très récemment c'est ce
sont des choses que l'on peut que l'on
peut entendre ou en tout cas lorsque la
personne ne va pas continuer à vanter
l'oeuvre coloniale ou essayer de mettre
en balance des choses dire bon en fait
c'est fini arrêtez de nous en parler
parce qu'en fait il faut se tourner vers
l'avenir et ne nous ramener pas sans
cesse à se passer à part que évidemment
ici on est sur différents procédés qui
visent à éviter
le sujet c'est qu'en fait la période
coloniale est une période d'une
gigantesque violence et on ne peut pas
penser qu'une période aussi violente sur
relativement longue au moins des
décennies quoi qu'il en soit serait
s'arrêterait du jour au lendemain c'est
impossible évidemment qu'il y a une
continuité évidemment le colonialisme il
y a eu l'esclavagisme aussi le
colonialisme a aussi eu comment dire la
dimension esclavagiste qu'il a sur une
période encore plus longue que le second
empire colonial français d'ailleurs bâti
en grande partie par la Troisième
République qui nous met aussi au cœur de
contradiction c'est qu'en fait c'est la
République qui fait triompher les idéaux
de la Révolution française la
Déclaration des Droits de l'Homme et du
Citoyen parce que c'est comme ça la
Troisième République c'est la même qui
va constituer en grande partie le second
empire colonial français et l'Empire
colonial français va être à un apogée
sous la Troisième République et on voit
bien qu'en fait là on est au cœur de
contradiction qui interroge très
profondément la façon dont la France
s'est construite dont la République
s'est construite d'où aussi tous ces
procédés discursifs des vêtements de
démonisation de ceux qui viendraient
dire attendez cette histoire-là n'est
pas finie parce qu'en fait on n'a pas
envie de l'entendre à part que
évidemment quand on n'a pas envie de
l'entendre c'est un une garantie que ça
continue parce qu'en fait pour régler un
problème encore faut-il le dire parce
que on ne règle pas un problème qu'on
n'est même pas capable de prononcer soit
parce que en fait profondément on pense
que finalement la figure de l'autre elle
doit être domestiquée et que finalement
cette figure bon peut-être qu'elle se
plaint mais quand même
la police
l'écrasement les discriminations c'est
pas forcément si mal que cela parce que
au moins il reste à sa place même si on
ne le cela vous pas aussi clairement à
soi-même cette approche universaliste
est un peu remise en question
aujourd'hui à travers les propos tenus
par un certain de collectifs on pense
aux collectif Adama on pense
aux indigènes de la République c'est une
ce sont ce qu'on appelle les décoloniaux
alors faut on essaie de mettre des
termes sur une approche plus racisée de
cette question lui font Deano il était
une universaliste d'ailleurs Kevin Boko
victoire qui vient d'écrire un livre
consacré à Franz Fanon nous dit fanons
dit que le n'est pas pas plus que
le blanc qui a mieux à faire que de
venger ses ancêtres qu'il n'y a pas de
destin noir son approche c'était
universaliste
son approche était universaliste au sens
large du terme oui
est-ce qu'on peut parler d'universalisme
républicain j'en doute concernant Fanon
parce que justement c'est une approche
universaliste décentrée
c'est ça en fait c'est à dire que il n'y
a pas de cause étrangère pour lui un
homme qui étouffe est
ils sont soucis mais
il ne pense pas qu'il y a une centralité
de valeur
qu'il faut répandre sur l'ensemble du
monde des valeurs entre guillemets
civilisatrices par exemple
et il fait et ça c'est très drôle c'est
que d'ailleurs c'est pas dans le film
Fanon il en a fait l'expérience même
c'est à dire qu'il arrive en Algérie
plein de bonnes volonté bien sûr et il
fait un ciné club en Algérie et montre
des films occidentaux
sauf que son ciné club n'a pas du tout
de succès auprès des de ce qu'on
appelait à l'époque les indigènes pas du
tout de succès et il se rend compte
qu'en fait il ne peut pas soigner les
gens non seulement dans le contexte
colonial mais aussi il ne peut pas
soigner les gens n'importe comment
c'est-à-dire dans n'importe quel
contexte culturel c'est à dire que il
faut bien sûr porter son aide à l'homme
qui étouffe mais en fonction aussi de
son environnement et de ses réalités
culturelles je crois que vous
souhaiteriez réagir à ce qu'elle dit
Dominique sa peau aussi oui tous les
trois des
très important c'est ce qui est dénoncé
en fait parce que vous appelez des
coloniaux par ces collectifs là qui
militent
ces sujets même les chercheurs
cherchent à mettre des mots sur les
moments actuels
colonial c'est certain mais aussi un
procédé de disqualification de ces
comités et de ses communautés de ces de
ces comités vérités et justice qui qui
sont légion depuis plusieurs années
[Musique]
ce qu'on oppose aux personnes aux
militants qui dénoncent en général c'est
justement on leur dit mais la France est
un État universaliste le droit et le
même pour tous donc on pourra pas faire
de lois spécifiquement de race et ça
sauf que c'est le même personne celles
qui sont mortes ou celles qui leur
ressemblent sont constamment renvoyées
dans différents domaines de leur vie à
quelque chose de particulier qui tout
d'un coup est complètement oublié
disparaît au moment où elle demande une
égalité de droit pour des questions de
justice on va revoir un extrait du
documentaire pour rebondir sur ce que
vous venez de dire c'est Benjamin Stora
l'historien qui s'exprime sur les
tiraillements moraux de Franz Fanon
la difficulté pour un homme comme Fanon
précisément c'est de se penser à la fois
comme français et non français français
par l'égalité liberté la République les
principes la libération etc et pas
français par la question coloniale et
par le statut wallonien donc il y avait
cette espèce d'interférence permanente
entre une république affichée proclamée
universel bien sûr et puis la réalité la
réalité vécue ça rejoint tout à fait ce
que vous venez de dire et ça c'est le
sentiment de partage beaucoup
aujourd'hui
qui sont peut-être issus de ce
du poste colonial justement
il y a un racisme ressenti qui ne
correspond absolument pas à cette grande
idée quelle universalisme oui enfin ou
en tout cas l'universalisme d'abord ça
ne peut pas être un européocentrisme
parce que c'est comme toujours étrange
ces gens qui parlent d'universalisme
mais quand même l'univers se réduit à
leur maison c'est étonnant quand on veut
embrasser l'univers commencer en disant
bah en fait je suis l'univers et
l'univers réel va se plier à mon univers
moral et de valeur si vraiment on est
universaliste on s'intéresse à l'univers
et dans l'univers il y a beaucoup de
choses il y a beaucoup de pensées il y a
beaucoup de culture il y a beaucoup de
courant et on remarque souvent que les
personnes qui parlent avec le plus de
force de l'universalisme connaissent
très peu de choses de l'univers déjà est
un premier comment dire est un premier
problème le deuxième élément c'est que
quand on parle de l'université ça peut
pas être un masque ça ne peut pas être
un masque pour éviter d'évoquer des
problèmes l'universalisme c'est aussi
l'universalité des droits si vraiment
l'entend bien l'universalité des droits
l'universalité de la dignité elle
demande de justement prendre à bras le
corps les questions de racisme et non
pas de les nier derrière des concepts
définis de façon très particulière et
finalement détourner de ce pourquoi au
point de départ même ils ont été forgés
là le racisme les discriminations vous
parliez tout à l'heure de on évoque
l'égalité nous qu'on a commencé
systématiquement à faire des testings et
SOS Racisme à la fin des années 90 début
d'année 2000 on nous disait bah attendez
oui il peut y avoir du racisme ici ou là
mais enfin la France c'est l'égalité
d'accord c'est peut-être l'égalité mais
c'est une proclamation et la question
c'est comment on fait pour que ce qui
est proclamé rentre dans la vie concrète
des gens ce qui n'est pas le cas quand
l'expérience c'est le contrôle officiel
c'est les discriminations raciales dans
toute une série de domaines dont autant
de phénomènes qui sont encore très
massivement niés le contrôle offensias
c'est très étonnant la façon dont en
fait il y a pas de débat possible
institutionnellement c'est pas possible
dans débattre tout le monde sait que ça
existe un n'importe quelle étude montre
que ça existe dès qu'on étudie le
phénomènes il y a même deux fois plus de
contrôle aux faciès
lorsqu'on a une couleur de peau qui
n'est pas blanche ah on est beaucoup
plus contrôlé par la police de façon
manifeste toutes les études
il n'y a pas une solitude qui montrerait
l'inverse pour toutes les personnes qui
se sont penchées dessus pour autant vous
remarquerez que institutionnellement il
est impossible d'avoir un débat sur le
sujet et là on est vraiment dans
quelques choses de d'une négation qui
est une forme de violence au-delà même
du contrôle c'est la négation c'est
impossible à écouter Dominique Sopo vous
avez vous une explication
sociologique où il y a une explication
très claire c'est le fait ce que vous
dites au début de votre propos c'est le
une société c'est
[Musique]
c'est pas ce qu'on imagine il y a un
idéal c'est certain qu'on partage on est
très nombreux partagés mais concrètement
une société c'est le maintien des
inégalités la vérité c'est ça c'est
qu'il y a une stratification sociale
qu'on a un rapport dominé à dominant à
dominé et que
les critères qui permettent aux
différencier les gens de hiérarchiser
et de stratifier donc c'est de c'est le
critère qu'on connaît tous de classe qui
est le plus connu celui de genre dont on
parle de plus en plus depuis quelques
années celui des origines de l'unicité
de la question raciale on s'arrange avec
le terme comme comme on le souhaite
c'est les trois principaux disons qui
permettent de répartir les biens
matériels les biens symboliques de
manière inégalitaire et c'est des
critères aussi qui exposent à la
violence et lorsqu'on cumule certains de
ces critères on est davantage exposé la
violence que d'autres et c'est tout à
fait le cas en ce qui concerne le
racisme
c'est vrai que l'oeuvre de Franz fannon
c'est beaucoup diffusé alors il y a des
périodes à beaucoup faire référence à
Franz Fanon d'autres moins
les livres consacrés à
la décolonisation l'enceinte de la
Révolution algérienne et surtout les
damnés de la terre qui sont dernier
livre troisième ouvrage de référence en
tout cas préfacé par Jean-Paul Sartre en
celui-là il y a des interprétations
différentes qui ont été faites les Black
Panthers qui ont beaucoup cités et qui
sont beaucoup appuyés sur l'oeuvre de
Franz Fanon ont mis en avant la violence
nécessaire selon eux à la lecture des
oeuvres de Fanon à mettre en oeuvre dans
la lutte anticholinaliste et antiraciste
c'était vraiment la réalité de la pensée
de Franz Fanon il fallait en arriver à
la violence pour obtenir gain de cause
et s'émanciper vis-à-vis de la puissance
coloniale ça dépend des comptes des
contextes ça dépend des contextes dans
le contexte colonial algérien par
exemple c'était une évidence pour fanon
d'ailleurs je pense qu'on a les
Algériens n'ont pas eu besoin de famille
au fond pour faire leur combat même s'il
a été un porte-parole important et c'est
sans doute pour ça qu'il a rejoint le
rang du FLN oui et alors pour clarifier
rapidement autour de cette question de
la violence
Franz Fanon voit la violence le passage
à l'acte la lutte armée comme un moment
nécessaire à la libération dans les
lieux de décolonisation et les luttes
nationales comme celle de l'Algérie et
le voit comme un passage nécessaire mais
il voit comme un passage
son objectif
ultime
n'est pas la violence son objectif
ultime et de canaliser tout un tas de
choses à travers ce passage à l'acte si
cette violence est organisée d'une
certaine manière il le décrit longuement
dans son dans son dans les années de la
terre
de canaliser cette violence qu'elle
servent à ce que
les coloniser
se refasse se refasse même décide pour
eux-mêmes se lâche s'extirent d'une
sorte de fixité s'extirent de de tout ce
qu'il les a justement effacés
et une fois que c'est fait si c'est bien
fait selon nous
ça laisse espoir pour l'avenir ça laisse
espoir pour se devenir dont on parlait
au début et ça ça permet aux hommes de
s'assumer en tant qu'homme en tant
qu'individu Dominique se pose la
question de la violence d'abord il faut
comprendre que le racisme c'est la
violence faut quand même pas oublier
quand on parle de la question de la
violence faut pas oublier que le
colonialisme le racisme c'est ça la
source d'abord c'est violent et ça peut
être parfois la source de réponse qui
vont être des réponses en miroir Ça peut
évidemment exister ça peut même être
parfois la seule façon et le calgérien
on est un cas évidemment emblématique la
seule possibilité laissée pour secouer
le joug de l'oppression ensuite la
violence elle vient aussi du fait qu'il
n'y a pas d'espace de débat de dialogue
je veux dire quand on quand des
personnes veulent lutter contre le
racisme on pourrait dire qu'elle le font
de façon maladroite caricaturale tout ce
qu'on veut mais comme je dis souvent je
préfère des antiracistes maladroits que
des racistes trop à droite on demeurant
quand il n'y a pas d'espace de débat et
que en fait ce que l'on vous renvoie
c'est un colloque à la Sorbonne contre
les dangers du wokisme avec un ministre
de l'éducation nationale et toute une
série de gens qui parlent comment dire
dans une forme d'uneanimité de couleur
du danger des réunions non mixtes il y a
quand même un sujet qui est posé c'est
que finalement ça c'est un dispositif de
violence qui empêche les personnes
j'adire d'avoir la parole parce qu'ils
compris ceux qui bloquent la parole pour
eux trouve que cette parole elle est
violente à leur égard parce que dire les
choses on peut dire ça peut être vécu
comme violent dire qu'il y a du racisme
dire qu'il y a des comment dire qu'il y
a de l'oppression etc c'est inattendable
pour certains mais cette parole qui peut
paraître comme étant agressive qui peut
être désagréable à entendre et elle est
demeurant il faut bien l'entendre parce
que c'est aussi comme ça qu'on fait
société en entendant ce que l'autre a à
dire en lui faisant une place en faisant
une place à son discours sinon soit même
on produit les conditions d'une violence
davantage physique il y a peut-être des
outils à mettre en place alors SOS
Racisme est réputé pour pour les
testings et c'est vrai que
cette méthode détesting infuse
d'ailleurs un certain nombre
d'entreprises aujourd'hui vont peut-être
devoir payer des amendes suite à des à
des testings il n'y a pas de statistique
ethnique par exemple en France à
l'exception de la Nouvelle-Calédonie et
on comprend pourquoi ça ce genre d'outil
pourrait faire progresser le débat aider
à en parler davantage à mieux quantifier
les choses à mieux les appréhender
à votre avis c'est quelque chose qui
manque réellement oui dans en France
actuellement et ce qui est souvent
renvoyé comme argument c'est que ça
favoriserait le communisme
ce qui est à mon sens est un argument
fallacieux qui ce qui a pu générer le
soi-disant commutarisme en France ce
sont les politiques publiques
elles-mêmes qui ont créé des ghettos
dans les cités françaises notamment ça
ça crée du communitarisme mais les
personnes d'elles-mêmes ne vont pas
c'est pas quelque chose qu'on dessine un
matin de créer une communauté de se
replier sur soi et de patient intégrer à
la société française et donc c'est un
argument complètement fallacieux qui
vise c'est toujours à peu près le même
procédé quand quelque chose était mis
d'une volonté d'aller de l'avant de
faire entendre des voix de calculer de
quantifier sa discrimination et cette
violence en face il y a des procédés de
disqualification constant et celui-ci
est un exemple en fait où on va inverser
la responsabilité et accuser ce qu'ils
demandent des outils légaux pour avancer
de de faire violence ou de d'obstruer le
débat ou la démocratie il y a des
sociétés qui repoussent sur un système
communautariste je pense aux États-Unis
par exemple où existent ces fameux
statistiques ethniques est-ce que ça a
fait avancer le débat anti raciste aux
États-Unis alors je pense que d'abord
sur statistiques en fait on a beaucoup
de statistiques en France qui sont pas
directement des statistiques et
techniques mais qui sont des
statistiques qui permettent quand même
de quantifier l'ampleur en peut penser
notamment à l'étude trajectoire et
origines il y a quand même beaucoup
beaucoup de données sur sur le sujet je
pense que le problème il va au-delà de
une question de j'allais dire de
quantification parce que quand on sait
bien qu'il y a des discriminations
comment dire il y a des études sur les
15 dernières années qui montrent des
taux de discrimination raciale à travers
notamment la période du testing pas fait
par SOS Racisme mais par des
scientifiques qui font des études
relativement massives pour montrer des
ampleurs de discrimination mais ce que
l'on voit c'est que même lorsque les
outils existent même lorsque les
chiffres existent ça n'est pas une
solution magique pour régler le problème
d'ailleurs on pourrait prendre un autre
champ les inégalités hommes femmes je
veux dire elles sont très quantifiées
pour le coup vous remarquerez il
paraîtrait que les femmes continuent à
être moins rien payer que les hommes bon
malgré les statistiques demeurant donc
il y a les statistiques les chiffres les
données l'objectivation de la chose et
des outils pour voir si ça évolue
positivement aussi ça stagne mais après
il y a la volonté politique et là on
peut très bien avoir des données mais
que ces données en fait on en fasse rien
sauf de façon très ponctuelle je dis
souvent par exemple sur les
discriminations raciales en France on en
parle en général quand SOS Racisme fait
un testing et on en parle pendant deux
jours voilà
comment ça en 2018 en 2022 en 2023 bon
on peut nous faire le coup comme ça
pendant encore 40 ans il y a encore ça
d'accord et en fait alors le buzz nous
c'est ce qu'on recherche aussi de faire
du buzz pour en faire parler mais la
question c'est comment ça s'encre dans
la durée et comment c'est saisi par la
politique publique à un moment donné ou
par les différents acteurs économiques
de notre pays pour faire en sorte que
vraiment ça change parce que pour nous
le but c'est pas de faire des marketing
pour dire qu'il y a des discriminations
c'est le fait qu'il y ait plus de
discrimination même si on en est encore
très très loin que je les sous les yeux
le baromètre mis en place par le Conseil
représentatif des associations noires le
cran sur un échantillon de 807 personnes
représentatives de la population
française noire ou métisse d'ascendance
noire et qui révèle que 91% de ces
personnes interrogées ont répondu à être
victime de discrimination raciale 85% de
ce même panel déclare avoir été victime
de discrimination liée à la couleur de
la peau
c'est assez parlant il y a d'autres
chiffres ceux de la Commission nationale
consultative des droits de l'homme qui
semblent plus positifs au premier regard
là aussi sur un baromètre annuel mis en
place par cette commission nationale 15%
des répondants se disent plutôt racistes
ou un peu raciste alors ça se sont
intéressants parce qu'en 2000 c'était
43% des Français interrogés à se dire
plutôt raciste ou un peu raciste donc
une progression qui semble positive
lorsqu'on parle de lutte antiraciste et
puis ce sont les personnes les plus
âgées qui sont les plus nombreuses à se
déclarer racistes les sympathisants du
rassemblement national mais et puis
autre autre chiffre qui peut peut-être
faire réfléchir seul 6% des Français
considèrent qu'il y a des rats
supérieurs à d'autres un chiffre qui a
baissé de 8 points en 20 ans il y a des
raisons de se réjouir de ces chiffres
est-ce que ça veut dire que la lutte
antiraciste est notamment
le racisme post-colon pas le recul ou
avant ce pardon il y a le ressenti le
vécu des personnes racisées
dont les vous venez de citer les
chiffres qui sont quand même assez
écrasants plus de 90%
donc bon il y a aussi être raciste sans
se le dire ça c'est une possibilité on
peut être raciste malgré soi et
d'ailleurs c'est l'objet de nombreuses
études
venus justement de ces sphères des
coloniales de ce qu'on appelle le
bouquinisme etc c'est de montrer en quoi
il y a quelque chose qui infuse
qui infuse dans l'inconscient collectif
et qui peut nous rendre raciste mais
tout le monde dans la société et Fanon
justement a été un des premiers à parler
de cette intériorisation du racisme
qui elle-même est génératrice de
violences psychiques je vous ai vu
émettre un demi sourire l'un et l'autre
quand
c'est quelques chiffres tout à l'heure
et oui c'est très c'est compliqué les
sondages et les baromètres et les
baromètres c'est compliqué parce que ça
c'est une fenêtre de tir ça donne pas un
aperçu forcément très clair de ce qui de
ce qui est effectivement et dans la tête
des gens de ce qui se passerait vraiment
dans la société elle est chez
interpersonnelle à l'échelle systémique
structurelle etc donc c'est toujours
plus complexe que les chiffres ça vaut
pas bon signe que les 18-26 ans
aujourd'hui une fois que 6% à s'estimé
plutôt raciste j'aurais du mal à me fier
à ça c'est sûr que j'aurais besoin de de
d'une enquête plus étayée avec des
entretiens par exemple voilà c'est mon
côté sociologue historienne qui parle
c'est à dire que c'est c'est aussi des
chiffres qu'on peut donner pour faire le
buzz pour voilà pour dans des périodes
aussi où ça intéressant il y a beaucoup
d'opinions au monde des élections à
chaque fois il y a des sondages depuis
pareil des années quoi on peut retourner
loin dans le temps qui montre
effectivement qu'il y a plus de racisme
en France et puis il y a un retour du
racisme enfin du coup c'est très dur de
se fier à ça d'où mon demi-souris ce
qu'on peut dire c'est que d'abord on
peut avoir des réalités contradictoires
ce que dire ce sont des phénomènes qui
sont
relativement complexe la question du
racisme c'est pas d'ailleurs c'est pas
je suis raciste où je suis pas raciste
comme souvent bien plus complexe que
cela comme réalité donc ce sont des
réalités extrêmement mouvantes qui
peuvent surgir parce qu'on n'est pas non
plus de l'histoire elle est pas linéaire
c'est pas un progrès continu ou une
dégradation continue on voit bien en ce
moment qu'on est aussi dans un retour
d'une parole raciste quand même très
virulente enfin quand tu vois pour
prendre un exemple Éric Zemmour pendant
la campagne présidentielle il y a
quelques années jamais on aurait pu
croire qu'un personnage comme celui-là
pouvait à ce point exprimer de façon
aussi violente le racisme depuis la
retraite présidentielle si je puis dire
de Jean-Marie Le Pen
ça n'était pas j'allais dire arriver le
deuxième comme le grand emplacement
évidemment oui tout à fait des thèmes
comme le grand remplacement le deuxième
élément c'est qu'on peut penser
évidemment que dans les jeunes
générations il y a moins de préjugés
puisque notamment le sondage de la ou le
baromètre de la scène cdH et fait en
interrogeant les personnes sur toute une
série de préjugés et on voit bien que
génération après génération les préjugés
semblent de moins en moins prégnants
donc ça c'est évidemment une dimension
qui peut être positive mais cette
dimension positive c'est pas c'est pas
quelque chose d'acquis c'est des choses
qui sont encore une fois très mouvantes
on voit bien comment aujourd'hui toute
une série de groupes politiques essaient
de remobiliser la jeunesse et notamment
une jeunesse qui se vivrait comme étant
comment on dit français de lointaine
ascendance dans l'Hexagone et bien de
les remobiliser sur des logiques de
confrontation avec d'autres parties de
la jeunesse donc tout ça est une
question politique il y a pas de chemin
j'allais dire comme ça qui serait pris
c'est des combats c'est des c'est des
analyses c'est des propos c'est voilà
donc il faut se battre et bien ce sera
le mot de la fin merci vraiment un grand
merci à tous les trois spécialement à
vous un co-auteur du film et du portrait
de fantason que nous avons diffusé à
l'occasion de de cette émission
vos réactions ça sera bien sûr sur
hashtag de Badoc sur Twitter elles
seront à mon avis assez nombreuses à la
fin de cette émission et je compte sur
vous pour réagir à ce que seront ces
réactions merci aussi à Selma Sally qui
m'a aidé à préparer cette émission je
vous donne tout simplement rendez-vous
pour un prochain débat doc et ça sera
bien sûr avec son documentaire et son
débat très bientôt
[Musique]